so you mentioned pie charm let me ask
you the uh the big subjective question
what's the best IDE for Python and
you're extremely biased now that you're
with Microsoft
um is it pie charm vs code Vim or emex
historically I actually uh started out
with using Vim but when it was still
called VI
uh for a very long time I think from the
early 80s to uh
I'd say two years ago
I was emacs user nice between I'd say
2013 and 2018
I dabbled with pie charm
uh mostly because it had
had a couple of features I mean
pie charm
is like deriving an 18-wheeler truck
whereas emacs is more
oh
it's like driving uh your comfortable
Toyota car
that's that's that that you've had for a
hundred thousand miles and you know what
every little rattle of the car means
I was very comfortable in emacs uh but
there were certain things it couldn't do
it wasn't very good at at sort of at
least the way I had configured it
I didn't have very good Tooling in emacs
for finding a definition of a function
got it when I was at Dropbox
exploring a 5 million line python code
base
uh just grabbing all that code for where
they're where is there a class Fubar
Well turns out that if you grab all five
million lines of code there are many
classes with the same name
and so pycharm sort of once once you've
fired it up and once it's indexed your
repository uh was very helpful but as
soon as I had to edit code I would jump
back to emacs and do all my editing
there because I could type much faster
and switch between files when I was when
I knew which file I wanted much much
quicker and I never really got used to
the the whole pie charm user interface
yeah I feel torn in that same kind of
way because I've used pycharm off and on
exactly in that same way
and I feel like I'm just being an old
grumpy man
for not learning how to quickly switch
between files and all that kind of stuff
I feel like that has to do with
shortcuts that has to do with um I mean
you just have to get accustomed just
like with touch typing yeah you have to
just want to to learn that I mean if you
don't need it much you don't need touch
typing either you can type with two
fingers just fine in the short term but
in the long term your life will become
better psychologically and productivity
wise if you learn how to type with 10
fingers if you do a lot of keyboard
input before everyone emails and stuff
right like you look at the the next 20
30 years of your life you have to
anticipate where technology is going
um do you want to invest in handwriting
notes probably not more and more people
are doing uh typing versus handwriting
notes so you can anticipate that so
there's no reason to actually practice
handwriting there's more reason to
practice typing
you could actually estimate back to the
spreadsheet the number of
paragraphs sentences or words you write
for the rest of your life
yes I mean all of that is not actual
like converting to a spreadsheet but
it's a gut feeling like I have the same
kind of gut feeling about books I've
almost exclusively switched to Kindle
now so ebook readers
even though I still love and probably
always will the smell the feel of a
physical book
and
you the reason I switched to Kindle is
like all right well this is really
Paving the future is going to be digital
in terms of consuming books and content
of that nature so you should get you
know you should let your brain get
accustomed to that experience
in that same way it feels like pie charm
or vs code I think pycharm is is the the
most sort of sophisticated featureful uh
python ID it feels like I should
probably at some point very soon switch
entire like I'm not allowed to use
anything else for python than this ID or
vs code it doesn't matter but walk away
from emacs for this particular
application because I think I'm limiting
myself in the same way that using two
fingers for typing is limiting myself
it's um this is a therapy session this
isn't I'm not even asking questions
but I'm sure a lot of people are
thinking that's going to stop you uh
I I think that that sort of everybody
has to decide for themselves which one
they want to to invest more time in
I actually
ended up giving vs code a very tentative
try when I started out at Microsoft and
really liking it
and it sort of it took me a while before
I realized why that was
but and and I think that actually the
founders of vs code may not necessarily
agree with me on this
but to me vs code is in a sense the
spiritual successor of emacs
because
as you probably know as an old emacs
hack
the the key part of emacs is that it
it's mostly written in in lisp
and that that sort of new features of of
emacs usually update all the list
packages and add new list packages and
oh yeah there's also
some very obscure thing improved in the
part that's not in lisp
but that's usually not why you would
upgrade to a new version of emacs
there's a core implementation that that
sort of
can read the file and it can put bits on
the screen and it can sort of manage
memory and buffers and then what makes
it an editor full of features is all the
list packages and of course the design
of how the list packages interact with
each other and with that that sort of
that base layer
of of the the core immutable engine
without almost everything in that core
engine in emacs case can still be
overridden or replaced
and so
vs code has a similar architecture where
there is like
a base engine that you have no control
over
I mean it's open source but nobody
except the people who work on that part
changes it much
uh and it has a sort of a package
manager
and a whole series of interfaces for
packages and an additional series of
conventions for how packages should
interact with the lower layers and with
each other
and Powerful primitive operations that
let you
move the cursor around or select pieces
of text or delete pieces of text or
interact with the keyboard and the mouse
and whatever peripherals you have
and and so the sort of the the extreme
extensibility and the package ecosystem
that you that you see in vs code is a is
a mirror of very similar architectural
features in emacs well I'll have to give
it a serious try because uh
as far as sort of the hype and the
excitement in the general programming
Community vs code seems to dominate the
interesting thing about
uh pie charm and uh what is it PHP storm
which are these jet brains uh specific
IDs that are designed for one
programming language it's interesting to
when an ID is specialized right they're
usually actually just specializations of
IntelliJ because underneath it's all the
same
editing Engine with different
veneer on top
where in vs code
many things you do
require
loading third-party extensions
in pie charm it is possible to have
third-party extensions
but it is it is a struggle to create one
yes and it's not part of the culture all
that kind of stuff yeah we that I
remember that might have been five years
ago or so we were trying to get some
better my Pi integration into pie charm
because my pie is sort of python tooling
and Pie charm
had had its own
type checking heuristic thing that we
wanted to replace with uh something
based on my pie because that was what we
were using in the company and it for the
for the guy who was writing that
by charm extension it was really a
struggle to to sort of find
documentation and get the development
workflow going and and debug his code
and all that so that that was was not a
pleasant experience